[Applaudissements]
directeur de la rédaction de télé câble
sat hebdo
françois est ce que vous avez encore de
la crédibilité moi je la portais la
prochaine conférence de rédaction mais
sérieusement vous allez porter cette
semaine oui allez shalit avant sa
rédaction
et si vraiment les équipes continuent à
vos équipes vous écoutez c'est vraiment
que c'est des kiwis je rentrais même la
chanson d'antoine vayer mama diva n'a
coupé ma mère j'ai répondu dans un temps
si tu veux le problème c'est ça c'est
l'escale escalade de l'horreur mauvaise
on l'applaudît quand même
[Applaudissements]
rigolo comme vêtement devient j'ai
remarqué en m'approchant vous avez un
zip semapa des boutons et ce à la
poitrine de tom selleck et on attend
toujours